[Musik]
frankreich im dezember mut demos
ausschaltung
die leute rufen telefonat das land
bewusst alle hassen die polizei woher
kommt dieser hass mein name ist jemand
für training wenn ich heute in paris
ich will wissen was in diesem land
gerade passiert ich will die wut der
bevölkerung verstehen aber auch hören
was die anderen seite die polizei da zu
sein
ich will mit der kamera mitten rein und
das ganze für euch dokumentieren los
geht's am platz der republik mitten im
lot sind die heute tausende menschen
zusammengekommen um gegen ein neues
polizeigesetz zu protestieren
es geht um das los security global ein
neues sicherheitsgesetz gegen das online
seit wochen stimmung gemacht wird kurz
vor der demut trainiert das hashtag auf
twitter besonders umstritten der artikel
24 er soll verbieten bilder von
polizistinnen zu verbreiten die ihnen
schaden können kritiker innen befürchten
dass das de facto zu einem film verbot
führt dabei tauchen besonders in den
vorstädten immer wieder videos von
brutalen für die zwei aktionen auf die
das land schockieren und zur
ausschreibung für den september sorgt
dann ein kinofilm für furore der die
polizeigewalt der letzten jahre mit
hilfe von handy aufnahmen dokumentiert
und kurz vor der demo geht ein video
viral in dem polizisten scheinbar
grundlos auf einen musikproduzenten
einschlagen
das heißt die stimmung weiter auf und es
zeigt welche macht online videos haben
heute vielleicht im gefängnis war die
polizistin behauptet hätten er hätte sie
geschlagen oder nach ihren waffen
gegriffen
genau deswegen ist es wichtig dass wir
uns heute hier gegen das gesetz stark
machen
entschuldigung drei sekunden das ist das
plakat
hallo tabu ist aktivist und einer der
organisatoren der dem er kämpft seit
jahren gegen polizeigewalt und rassismus
seine waffe social media solche bilder
verbreiten sich heute viel schneller auf
social media als im fernsehen
es sind doch längst die sozialen
netzwerke die den sendern die themen
diktieren
social media ist heute ein mittel der
verteidigung und hat es möglich gemacht
das thema polizeigewalt auf die
tagesordnung zu setzen
und hh weiß wovon er spricht
2018 filmte das grobe einschreiten von
sicherheitskräften in paris
[Applaus]
[Musik]
was damals noch nicht ahnt sein video
wird eine staatsaffäre auslösen
denn nachdem der clip online die ral
geht wird klar der mann im fokus ist
kein polizist
es ist alexandre panel
sicherheitsberater und vertrauter von
makro- und der gerät in erklärungsnot
zwei jahre später steht die regierung in
sachen sicherheitsfragen wieder in der
kritik
in den augen vieler betrifft der neue
gesetzesentwurf dabei vor allem die
vorstädte die boni lzh es sind die
jungen araber die jungen schwarzen also
die jugendlichen in den bars die dadurch
benachteiligt werden es trifft also die
opfer von polizeigewalt und willkür und
die werden keine mittel mehr haben sich
zu verteidigen
solche aufnahmen sind die einzige
möglichkeit für diese menschen für taha
wie für einen großteil der linken szene
in frankreich sind die rollen klar
verteilt
aber es ist wirklich so einfach fest
steht ich muss irgendwie rein kommen die
bonis das wird nicht leicht aber dazu
später mehr
hier auf der demo wird noch alles
friedlich es sind aber ausschreitungen
angekündigt gefühlt demonstriert hall
paris trotz corona und lockdown und das
alles wirklich nur um die polizei film
zu dürfen
in der menge treffe ich sie und der
sieht aus als hätte er einiges zu dem
thema zu sagen er ist reporter streams
soziale proteste ins netz und laut ihm
stellt das ganze gesetz eine gefahr dar
viele leute fokussieren sich nun auf den
artikel 24
aber denk dran es gibt nicht nur den
sagt mir in den kommentaren was ihr von
dem gesetz dem artikel 24 und allen
anderen halten neben dem artikel 24
regelt das gesetz auch andere
umstrittene aspekte
es geht zum beispiel um mehr mittel und
befugnisse für die lokale polizei um das
tragen von body camps seitens der
sicherheitskräfte und um überwachung per
drohne so viel sei gesagt in den
kommentarspalten unterschieds videos
finden sich nicht viele fans von polizei
und regierung
aber in seinen augen schaffen des
streams mehr objektivität
manchmal sind es die demonstranten die
anfangen das will ich nicht abstreiten
aber manchmal ist es eben auch die
polizei
deswegen bin ich hier und filme alles im
live stream um das alles zu zeigen um
die verhaftung zu zeigen den
machtmissbrauch die polizeigewalt von
gewalt sprechen hier viel obwohl noch
nicht viel zu sehen ist merke ich wie es
zu brodeln beginnt und wirklich auf
einmal wird es laut so jetzt hat sich
die stimmung hier langsam auf wir
schauen mal was da geht
ich folge juni menge wo sich jetzt ein
schwarzer block formiert und die
stimmung kippt
[Musik]
und auf einmal steht zwischen den
fronten ich merke dass sie es verdammt
ernst und ich kann es nicht mehr
kontrollieren
jetzt wird die gewaltserie überall
tränengas ich bekomme keine luft mehr
muss ich erst mal raus realisieren was
gerade passiert und julis weg und auf
einmal bin ich mitten im schwarzen block
und es wird hektisch hier will man nicht
gefilmt werden so viel klar
irgendwie fühlt sich das nach
doppelmoral schon klar gewalt erzeugt
gegengewalt aber ob es hier wirklich
noch um die sache geht darüber lässt
sich streiten aber wozu hat youtube
kommentare was meint ihr
[Applaus]
apropos youtube wie viele leute schauen
zu gerade waren wir so 5000 auf youtube
und facebook auch nochmal so 5000
ungefähr
ich versuche den livestream jetzt neu zu
starten aber mit geringerer auflösung
für hd reichte empfang nicht
wir sind gasflaschen hier in dem lkw
macht euch keine sorgen alles läuft gut
aber durch das appell lässt sich der
mord nicht beirren und dann regelt die
polizei die situation auf ihre weise die
tränengasgranaten treffen randalierer
innen und friedliche demonstrierende
gleichermaßen für mich eine neue und
definitiv und schöne erfahrung
denn die deutsche polizei kann bei demos
von schlagstöcken pfefferspray und im
notfall wasserwerfern gebrauch machen
aber in frankreich gehören auch
distanzwaffen zum repertoire
dazu zählen granatwerfer
tränengasgranaten gummigeschoss werfer
das ergebnis sind oft martialische
bilder und junge menschen die sich
dagegen wehren wir sind so viele junge
menschen weil unsere freiheit
eingeschränkt werden soll
und ich glaube wir sind viel politischer
als zum beispiel unsere eltern früher
ging alles über die eltern oder die
schule aber jetzt politisieren wir uns
selbst dank twitter facebook und co gül
habe ich jetzt endgültig verloren
erst mittendrin und filmt dort wo es
abseits der demo zwischen randalierern
und polizei knallt diese videos schickt
er mir später
ich weiß nicht wie es euch geht mir
fällt es schwer zu beurteilen wer hier
welche grenzen überschreitet und
zugegeben polizist wäre ich da auch
nicht gerne also weg von diesem chaos
und zurück zur demo wo die mehrheit der
demonstrierenden sich konstruktiv mit
dem thema beschäftigt mir wird klar hier
sind nicht alle personen die polizei
aber es scheint grundlegende probleme zu
geben
die polizei ist nötig um menschen und
bürgerrechte zu garantieren
aber diese staatsgewalt darf nicht von
denen missbraucht werden die sie
ausführen sondern muss allen
gleichermaßen denen und das bringt nicht
zurück zur frage wieso ist die menschen
hier so wichtig ist die polizei fühlen
zu dürfen
unter französische polizist innen
wirklich alle rassistischen gewalt
bereit sind auf meiner to-do-liste für
die nächsten tage stehen gespräche mit
den polizistinnen und den betroffenen
wie nah ist wirklich ankommen kann weiß
ich noch nicht
denn die stimmung im land ist explosiv
auch hier nach dem offiziellen demo ende
kippt es schon wieder
die leute rufen telefoniert es klappt
rohstoffe alle hassen die polizei das
ist glaube ich ganz gut wie verhärtet
die freundin ihr sehr viel sprengkraft
in dem ganzen thema stellt die demo die
ausschreitung aber auch das ganze thema
polizeigewalt haben ziemlich für
schlagzeilen gesorgt werden im ganzen
land hitzig diskutiert ich treffe mich
doch einfach mit einem der organisatoren
der demo um nochmal in ruhe über das
ganze sprechen zu können
der anwalt vertritt opfer von
polizeigewalt und deren geschichten sind
oft schockiert es gibt immer mehr
menschen die von der polizei brutal
festgenommen verletzt und manchmal sogar
getötet werden
bei ganz normalen kontrollen ich denke
da an einen meiner klienten city schoss
das ist ein mann der ist 42 jahre alt
hat fünf kinder arbeitet er ist auf dem
roller und macht eine lieferung und dann
wird er kontrolliert erhält annimmt sein
handy und filmt die polizei weil er
findet dass die kontrolle nicht
gerechtfertigt ist
und dann kommt es zu einem wortwechsel
ein bisschen zynisch sarkastisch
zwischen den polizisten und ihm und er
stirbt
gegen die polizistinnen läuft derzeit
ein verfahren
hauptbeweismittel sind die handy videos
der augenzeuginnen nur dank der videos
die uns nach unserem zeugenaufruf über
social media zugesandt wurden ist die
wahrheit heraus gekommen und zwar dass
das pariser polizeipräsidium gelogen hat
denn sie hatten behauptet es hätte sich
bei city schoss tod um einen herzinfarkt
gerettet
[Musik]
es sind fälle wie dieser die den anwalts
mobilmachung gegen das gesetz antreiben
die polizei sei genügend geschützt meint
er und das gesetz ein falsches zeichen
das paradigma dieses gesetzes ist dass
der staat die gesamte bevölkerung sieht
ohne dass die bevölkerung den start
sehen kann und das ist eine form der
gesellschaft die wir nicht wollen
ganz ehrlich beim anblick solcher bilder
kann ich irgendwie verstehen dass die
bevölkerung das vertrauen in die
staatsgewalt verliert aber was sagt die
polizei selbst ich bin auf dem weg nach
wie richard janssen bonn im süden von
paris da haben zwei polizeibeamte ein
gewinn nicht mit mir zu sprechen
extrem gespannt was sie über das gesetz
die proteste und auch ihre arbeit in
bonn wir zu sagen haben und vor allem
die offensive sprechen werden
wie gehen die gesetzeshüter einen mit
explosiven stimmung im land um
[Applaus]
ich muss zugeben all das was ich über
die französische polizei gehört habe hat
bei mir spuren hinterlassen
es fühlt sich falsch an jetzt mit dem
streifenwagen durch die bonnie ist zu
fahren
aber mir ist es wichtig auch diese
perspektive zu verstehen das hier ist
ein viertel jawala da hat gerade ein
polizeieinsatz
ganz typisch eine kontrolle der
nationalpolizei das ist ein viertel in
dem immer wieder kleine drogengeschäfte
abgewickelt werden und oft große gruppen
unterwegs sind
sehen sie diese wege da wenn es schlecht
läuft können wir da leicht in die zange
genommen und angegriffen werden
die police minimal ist die örtliche
polizei sie untersteht der gemeinde und
soll der direkte draht zur bevölkerung
seien in der vorstadt wie hier nicht
immer einfach
so jetzt machen wir eine kleine
sicherheits runde sicherheits runde in
bonn
ich las die kamera laufen aber das stößt
bei einigen auf wenig verständnis
und plötzlich werde auch ich gefilmt und
ich muss zugeben irgendwie schon ein
komisches gefühl
was ist denn passiert
ach die nationalpolizei ist gekommen und
dann sind hier alle abgehangen und ein
paar von den kids sind in den laden aber
ohne maske
da müssen wir eine kleine verwarnung
aussprechen hier bleibt heute alles
ruhig aber immer wieder stehen brutale
polizeieinsätze in den banlieues in der
kritik für den polizeidirektor liegt die
ursache auch im system ein problem ist
dass manchmal die jüngsten polizisten
also die die noch ganz am anfang der
ausbildung stehen in die komplizierten
viertel geschickt werden und dann kann
stress entstehen der manchmal zu
aggressivem verhalten führt man muss
erstmal lernen das alles zu kanalisieren
als junger polizist in so einem viertel
es ist nicht einfach sich beschimpfen zu
lassen sich mit steinen bewerfen zu
lassen
ja das alles passiert unser ausbildungs
prozess muss sich auch an diese
situation anpassen an das was wir
tatsächlich hier draußen erlebe
tatsächlich ist die ausbildung bei der
polizei in frankreich ziemlich kurz die
grundausbildung bei der stadtpolizei
dauert nur sechs monate bei der
nationalpolizei sind es je nach
polizeischule acht bis zwölf monaten
in deutschland dauert die ausbildung
mindestens 24 bei der bundespolizei
sogar 30 monate
bei all der kritik aus der bevölkerung
wünscht sich manuell je auch mehr
verständnis für die beamtinnen vor allem
in den sensiblen viertel
er will kein filmverbot sagt er aber die
verbreitung der videos sei für sie
gefährlich heutzutage sind wir
verwundbar wirklich verwundbar schon
wegen der sozialen netzwerke der ganzen
bilder die von polizeieinsätzen gemacht
werden
wir wollen einfach nur geschützt werden
was das angeht statistiken darüber wie
viele polizistinnen so wirklich zu
schaden kommen gibt es nicht aber die
angst ist auch bei ihnen groß
das erfahre ich als zurück auf die wache
kommen ein polizist wie lange mit mir
sprechen
[Applaus]
wir sind heute eine zielscheibe und ich
will vermeiden dass wir morgen jemand in
meinem sozialen oder persönlichen umfeld
entdeckt dass ich polizist bin das an
meiner familie aus lässt ich bin selbst
aus dem ball und das könnte übel enden
einige leute würden das falsch verstehen
ich will einfach nicht dass man mich
irgendwann erkennt wenn ich mit meiner
familie einkaufen bin
und jemand der mir etwas böses will
vergreift sich dann an meiner familie
toni das heißt eigentlich einfach nur
vor ort aber in frankreich steht das
wort für mehr die arbeiterviertel sind
brennpunkte in denen sich viele
problemlagen mission lebens ist das
verhältnis zwischen polizei und
bevölkerung so angespannt wie hier immer
wieder eskalieren kontrollen und es
kommt zu brutalen auseinandersetzungen
im viertel
für mich persönlich ist die realität der
boni es ziemlich weit weg also spreche
ich mit einer person die in frankreich
als stimme der vororte gilt und seit
jahren gegen polizeigewalt kämpft der
grund dafür ist der tod ihres bruders
2016 ist er da mal traurige tötet worden
ein junger schwarzer aus dem maul uhr
weil er ohne papiere auf der straße
unterwegs war und junge leute wie er da
mal gibt es viele
du musst verstehen seit diesem zeitpunkt
befinden wir uns im krieg mit der justiz
traurig ist sich sicher ihr kleiner
bruder wurde getötet
fest steht er wird bei einer
routinekontrolle verhaftet von den
beamten mit auf die wache genommen und
verstirbt
nach vier jahren protest wird der fall
jetzt noch einmal neu untersucht ein
teilerfolg für die familie assad raue
kritisiert die polizei und mittlerweile
hört frankreich hierzu auch sie war auf
der demo hält das neue gesetz für
gefährlich aber das problem sitzt tiefer
wir haben jetzt auch in den medien viel
von polizeigewalt auf den demos
natürlich auch weil da viele
journalistinnen und kameras sind und das
ganze gut dokumentiert wird
aber du sagst dahinter steckt auch ein
gesellschaftliches problem
die diskussion muss viel breiter geführt
werden wir müssen an der wurzel ansetzen
und nicht irgendwo in der mitte
sonst vergessen wir die dies ohnehin
schon schwerer haben und das sind die
menschen aus dem milieu heute trinke
gewalt bis in die innenstädte vor sie
ist mitten in der französischen
hauptstadt
also ist das problem jetzt ein
gegenwärtig aber das problem kann man
nicht lösen
ohne die gewalt in den more news zu
thematisieren niemand verteidigt diese
menschen niemand weint um sie niemand
sympathisiert mit ihnen um das wirklich
zu verstehen muss ich selbst rein in die
viertel diesmal ohne polizei dazu film
es nicht leicht viele menschen vertrauen
in medien nicht mehr aber über einen
französischen kollegen er halte ich ein
kontakt
wir sind gerade auf den weg nach sedrun
nie das ist ein bully im norden von
paris
da gibt es jemanden der mit uns über das
thema sprechen würde und es kann da gibt
sich auf filmen gespannt der ford von
paris berüchtigt vor allem für gewalt
und drogen bekannt
die arbeitslosigkeit ist hier doppelt so
hoch wie im französischen durchschnitt
am schlimmsten ist die lage in der cité
leben dort und genau dafür hat früher
hochklassig fußball gespielt und es
heute eine größe im viertel dank ihm
denn ich und meine kamera hier
akzeptiert theo setzt auf dialog
vermittelt wenn es ärger gibt unter den
cats doch geht es um die polizei kann
auch er nicht viel machen
vielleicht kann die neue generation in
zehn 15 oder 20 jahren wieder mit der
polizei in den dialog treten
aber im moment ist es zu angespannt der
ganze druck der ihr ausgeübt wurde das
sitzt tief dass wir uns ja ausgerechnet
am fußballplatz treffen ist kein zufall
denn für viele hier ist sport der
einzige weg raus aus dem viertel
ich spreche mit theus freund mahnung der
seinen kindern zuschaut und die probleme
hier täglich erfährt das ist wie ein
gefängnis hier
es gibt überhaupt keine möglichkeiten
und wie gesagt einige kids verlagen
ihrer wut ausdruck indem sie illegale
dinge tun aber das ist eine minderheit
das ist nicht die mehrheit her
und dann komme ich auch mit den jungs
selbst ins gespräch der neuen generation
wie theo sie nennt als sie mir von ihnen
erfahrung mit der polizei hier im
viertel erzählen werde ich mir meine
eigenen privilegien bewusst
wenn du mich als beispiel nimmst junger
typ ganz schwarz gekleidet wenn ich in
einem viertel rumlaufe wo drogen
verkauft werden
da werde ich ganz sicher kontrolliert
[Musik]
so viel steht fest die kids hier sind
die polizei bedrohung und nicht als
ihren freund und helfer und auch ich
muss noch einmal an die videos denken
die ich im netz gesehen hat selbst wenn
wir gar nichts machen kann es passieren
dass ein polizist der ist einfach
schlecht meint uns an macht und schlägt
sobald er kontrolliert werden haben wir
angst na ja keine angst aber wir
erwarten das schlimmste weil die
polizisten nicht von hier kommen haben
sie dieses bild im kopf von einem
dreckigen gefährlichen gewaltvollen
viertel
vielleicht haben sie auch einfach angst
und lassen das an allen anderen aus vom
problem mit der polizei erfährt man hier
vor allem aus snapshot und diese videos
sind für die jungs extrem wichtig und
unsere einzige waffe gegen die polizei
ist das film und das werden wir bald
nicht mehr haben
wir haben dann keine beweise mehr dann
heißt es ihre stimme gegen unsere und
dann werden sie immer gewinnen
sie repräsentieren frankreich das gesetz
natürlich wird immer auf sie gehört was
bedeutet dann social media social media
zeigt einfach wirklich die realität und
das baut druck auf auch wenn sie so tun
als würden sie es nicht sehen die
minister oder abgeordneten all die da
oben aber wir wissen dieses wir wissen
dass gedrungen
das baut druck auf und trotzdem
verschließen sie die augen
das ist traurig wenn das morgen ihren
kindern passiert oder jemandem aus ihrer
familie
dann werden wir davon plötzlich überall
hören plötzlich spüre ich wie gespalten
das land wirklich ist ja ich wusste
polizeigewalt ist ein problem aber die
ausmaße werden wir erst nach meinem
besuch im mondeo wirklich klar das recht
die polizei film zu dürfen bekommt ihr
eine neue bedeutung
und auch politisch bleibt es verfahren
zwar hat die regierung in paris
versprochen den gesetzestext nochmal zu
bearbeiten aber ich glaube nicht dass
das die proteste starben will
frankreich hat nicht nur ein problem mit
seiner polizei sondern auch mit seinem
vorstädten und beide gilt es zu lösen
es ist nicht uneingeschränkt möglich
bilder und videos von polizeieinsätzen
im netz zu verbreiten durch darüber
schon mal gedanken gemacht und könnt ihr
euch vorstellen dass die debatte auch
bei uns in deutschland schreibt mir eure
meinung in die kommentare und lasst es
uns diskutieren
[Musik]